[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir etwas
süßes und zwar auf das sind kleine mini
pfannkuchen gefüllt mit einer leckeren
milchprodukte und getränke zuckersirup
wie immer natürlich einen orientalischen
welt das rezept habe ich diesmal von
hannes schwester danke dafür das rezept
ich habe schon gesagt mein rezept ist
super man hat haben sie gesagt gib
probier doch mal das von meiner
schwester aus zwar lecker aber irgendwie
ist es ein bisschen anders
dann habe ich ausprobiert und dachte mir
nur so lecker wie zeige ich euch das
rezept gestalten die zuallererst mit dem
teil
wir benötigen lauwarme milch weichweizen
gries mehl backpulver trockenhefe und
etwas salz für den teig werden jetzt
ganz einfach alle sechs zutaten
miteinander verrührt er braucht noch
nicht mal ein handrührgerät oder die
küchenmaschine es geht ganz einfach mit
dem schneebesen wichtig ist nur dass die
milch lauwarm ist also das sollte die
schon beachten und jetzt gibt es erstmal
trockenen zutaten hinein und dann die
milch
jetzt verrät er das ganze klümpchen frei
und ich habe jetzt milch reingetan ihr
könnt auch wasser nehmen oder halb und
halb das geht auch aber da hat gesagt
mit nicht weg das besser deswegen gehen
wir natürlich nicht mein tag ist jetzt
komplett klümpchen frei ich zeig euch
mal die konsistenz so sieht er aus und
jetzt müssen wir den deckel drauf geben
oder einem teller hauptsache ist gut
verschlossen und dann einfach eine
stunde irgendwo auf zimmertemperatur
gehen lassen das ist ganz wichtig aber
benutzen die zwischenzeitig liebes
zwischenzeiten auszunutzen denn gleich
machen wir noch die milch pudding und
den zuckersirup sagte gleich ist euch
aufgefallen dass im teig gar kein zucker
war mir schon und die ganze süße kommt
durch den zuckersirup hunden hier die
zutaten einmal wasser etwas zitronensaft
und natürlich zuckersüße für die afg
kommt wirklich nur durch den zuckersirup
ja klar wenn mich ein bisschen zucker
aber nur ein bisschen
deswegen machen wir den jetzt als erstes
und dann zeige ich euch wieder mit polen
geht auf dem herd kochen wir jetzt
zucker zusammen mit dem was das wasser
zusammen mit dem zucker auf so könnte
auch kurz umrühren dann einmal aufkochen
lassen
so mein zucker wasser kocht gerade jetzt
gehen wir noch den saft der halben
zitrone rhein ist ganz wichtig und jetzt
weitere fünf minuten lang köcheln lassen
und dann ist der zucker sehr unfertig
und jetzt machen wir die füllung wir
machen anstatt das ist arabischer
milchprodukte ist super lecker ich hab
ich schon mal ein paar süßspeisen
gezeigt mit us-star die verleger die
durch auch nochmal unten in die infobox
falls sie daran interessiert seid wir
benötigen im zutaten milch sahne etwas
zucker außerdem speisestärke und ganz
wichtig sind rosenwasser und
orangenblüten wasser in türkischen
arabischen supermarkt und bevor ich den
herd einschaltete werden alle zutaten
rhein gegeben und krönchen frei verrührt
und dann schalten ines 1
fuchs das war nicht so elegant
haben sie denn ernst hörst du dich zu
schon sagen muss ich erst ruhe und damit
einen schaden
und jetzt nachdem alles klümpchen frei
verriet wurde einmal den herd
einschalten und dann unter ständigem
rühren einmal aufkochen
jetzt habe ich den pudding gerade
umgefüllt und jetzt müssen wir sofort
frischhaltefolie darüber geben damit
sich keine haut bildet so und jetzt
lassen wir das vollständig auskühlen
aber unsere pfannkuchen sind soweit das
heißt der teig also die pfannkuchen
backen jetzt auf und es hat so ihr
lieben die stunde ist um und jetzt
können wir den teig weiterverarbeiten
aber vorher ganz wichtig noch einmal
kräftig umrühren und jetzt wird der teig
ausgebauten und zwar nehmt ihr euch da
am besten eine schöpfkelle ihr könnt
selber entscheiden wie groß oder wie
klein er das ganze macht wichtig ist nur
dass ihr eine fettfreie beschichtete
pfanne benutzt und den herd auf mittlere
stufe stellt
ich backe jetzt immer ein pfannkuchen in
der pfanne aus damit ihr auch schön rund
sind und mich an den seiten verlaufen
denn am ende auch wirklich gut aus wenn
sie richtig schön rund und ich zeige
euch jetzt mal gemerkt dass es fertig
ist und zwar ist hier oben kein urteil
noch vorhanden und es haben sich
bläschen gebildet und jetzt nehmen wir
ihn aus unserer fahne und geben ihnen
dass es ganz wichtig in so ein sauberes
geschirr tuch zwischen zwei saubere
geschirrtücher so hier bist schon
vorbereitet und dann geben wir auch das
geschirrtuch wieder darüber
denn ansonsten kann das wirklich
passieren oder es passiert eigentlich
hundertprozentig dass der fang suchen
total trocken geht und ihnen
anschließend nicht mehr zusammen kleben
können
das heißt achtet auf jeden fall darauf
und jetzt mache ich so weiter bis ich
den teig vollkommen verarbeitet habe
können wir bitte darüber sprechen ist
haben sie eine geniale idee hatte man
kann sollte nämlich gesagt hallo ein
gefäß wo du dein tag eins und dann
werden wir immer gleich groß
du bist genial du bist ein training
wollte sich jetzt zeigt
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt der spaßige teil wir
befüllen nämlich die pfannkuchen mit dem
milch pudding unser erster ist nämlich
auch schon fertig und es richtig schön
fest geworden ich zeige euch jetzt mal
ganz kurz wie die pfannkuchen auszusehen
haben also sie sollten nicht dunkler als
wirklich goldbraunen sein denn sonst
schminken sie leicht bitter und jetzt
nehmen wir uns einen pfannkuchen ihr
könnt sie übrigens wollte ich euch auch
noch zeigen so mit denen mit der
innenseite übereinander lagern damit ihr
dann ein bisschen mehr platz gehabt auf
euren küchentuch und jetzt nimmt ihr
euch eben ein und immer schön verdecken
und dann mit einem löffel hier unsere
pudding füllung drauf geben und die
füllung verteidigt weiter vorne und
hinten eher weniger weil jetzt das ganze
verschlossen so dass man vorne die
füllung noch sieht und dadurch dass wir
das küchentuch drauf hatten klebt das
jetzt wie von alleine ist einfach nur
zusammendrücken und dann bleibt das
schön kleben
für die weitere sanierung habt ihr zwei
eigentlich unendliche möglichkeiten ich
zeige euch jetzt zwei die erste das sind
pistazien die habe ich in einem mixer
fein gemahlen und die zweite möglichkeit
die ich heute verwende das sind walnüsse
die habe ich ebenfalls fallen gemeint
und da gebe ich jetzt noch so ein
bisschen zimt rein dass es optional aber
ich finde das schmeckt super lecker und
jetzt einfach vorne die füllung
eintunken ich nehme jetzt hier
zuallererst pistazien einfach kopfüber
reihen schön andrücken und dann sind sie
eigentlich auch schon fertig
sobald ihr die teils dann gefüllt und
dekoriert hat sind so fast fertig denn
es fehlt noch der zucker sirup und ihr
braucht diese zuckersirup denn hier
kommt die ganze süße her
also macht es am besten bevor ihr einer
teils genießt am besten vorher in zucker
sirup drüber einige machen auch so und
ich finde es auch ganz gut wenn man hier
in die mitte den zuckersirup reihen gibt
und anschließend an einen archivar
eingibt das ist übrigens auch ein
superschönes mitbringen geschenk wenn
ihr mal beim besuch eingeladen sei denn
dass sie total schön aus findet das
macht richtig was her
und wenn ihr das auch noch rund
anrichtet und ich denke das richtig
schön voll mit so ein bisschen geschenkt
folie drum herum und ist das ein richtig
richtig tolles geschenk und spendiert
total gut probier zu gerne mal aus die
genauen mengenangaben stehen wie immer
hier unten in der infobox ich freue mich
sehr über eure fotos über instagram mit
dem hashtag iges kitchen vor allem mit
jungs sehr gespannt wie ihr sie dann
anrichtet ansonsten freue ich mich wenn
ihr mich abonniert damit ihr kein video
mehr verpasst und wir sehen uns dann
beim nächsten mal auf die gis kitchen
[Musik]